So the cool thing now is you can mess around
with these a little bit easier without
feeling like you're going to
Conflict with anything in the villain's
health
I forgot to actually invoke that awesome so
let's actually work with the hero's health
for now
So we've made those changes to our Crusaders
Health but I want to say if my crusader
Hero's health is less than or equal to
zeroLet's add that.
Change to him let's actually change that
image all together
So we already have access to our hero
elimFrom above so let's actually say oops.
NoSo in this.
So in this if statement let's go ahead and
go get my documentAnd we'll get element by
ID here.
And let's go get the code Works crusader
And let's actually make sure that is correct
cuz this is a common thing sometimes
you think you remember the ID so let's just
go ahead and double click itAnd bring it
over.
And on this one I'm going to call a unique
So now I'm going to call upon a unique
property
I can access a property called classless and
this classless if
I hit period again will give me all these
different
Well give me all these different methods I
can call upon
I can do an ad replace removing these this
is actually targeting that exact
ID and accessing all the classes so this I
want to add a class
In the class I want to add is going to be
dead crusader
I'll show that off with a debugger as well
what's going on hereBut first let's go
actually create that class.
So we'll actually have that deck Crusader at
the top here so we'll say dead crusader
And we want the content of this to be a
We'll just have it so the content of this
will be image that we have overAnd then also
add a filter.
Of a grayscale and I want that gray scale to
be oneJust make sure to add our semicolons
are awesome.
So now if we save all thisAnd go to our web
application.
It's good work console and actually set my
Hero's Health to one
So now when I hit attack my hero
shouldPerish. And we should also hit that
debugger.
Oh right it's all in the wounds man critical
hit so I don't think I refreshed
So let's try it again
Oh
hero
health
So this is miles from the future and because
of this debugger I was able to actually
figure out
Hero.hero Health doesn't exist
So I was actually not getting the response
that I wanted to on the web application so
this is just
another showing debugging and figuring it
out so when I had gone to zero it skipped
over this conditional all
together and at that point I noticed that I
had the wrong property in there so let's try
this again
Discovered our web application refresh and
hit that inspect toolLet's go to console and
I'll set the hero's Health to one.
So now when I attackWe hit this debugger
inside this if statement.
And now it's going to go over to this
document get element by ID
And it's going to add that class list of
debt crusader
So we get this gravestone here andI also
want to show that off let's actually not do
with the debugger here though.
So I willConsole log here this is going to
be a little bit extra way to do this but.
So we'll go get this code Works crusaderIt's
actually just. Copy and paste that.
And I want to show off the difference of
before and after the hero dies
So let's do the same I will set his health
to oneAnd then I will get critically hit
again.
And the big thing here is if you notice
right now
He's got both of them on
That don't make no sense
WhyWhy. Maybe it's happening too quick.
What is going on
That's annoyingOkay whatever.
So if I highlight this code Works Crusader
right now
We can see and hear that right now we haveA
class on him.
It's actually closes up a little bit better
and the only class that exists on him is
this height 75Not if I set his health to
one.
And attack
No the coating virus actually missed
And now we get that console log back and we
can see it added this new class dead
crusader
Only when he his health gets blow zeros cuz
right now is healthyIsn't below zero so it
won't actually take effect.
But nowRip. We actually get that class added
on there.
And that's all because of this classless
property here
And because of this dot ad so if you could
always highlight over this it will actually
show you the MDM reference which is really
handy
Like says it's just this property just
allows for manipulation of the elements
class content
And we're able to do that also because of
the add method
So anything I passed through here it's going
to add that to its class
So at this point we're going to do the same
exact thing with this villainSo we'll say
if.
The Honda helpIt's less than or equal to
zero.
Let's go get that document the same wayAnd
let's make sure we get the right index.
And we're going to do the same exact thing
we're going to access that classless
property and we're going to use the add
method
And on this one I want to add the class of
dead virus
So let's actually code out that's going to
be
So for dead virus we're not going to be so
dramatic with the gravestone he doesn't get
his own gravestone He's the bad guy
We're going to actually add in that filter
of grayscale as wellWhich should gray out
his character.
And then let's also transform we're going to
we're going to flip them upside down so
we're going to scale on the Y axi
And we're going to do a negative one so
we're going to flip it all the way around
If I chose the X here it would actually flip
around the horizontal and I'll show that off
as well
So if weSo if I set the villain tell to one
now.
We said that to oneAnd now when I attack.
We get the code Works virus flipped around
on its head and gray scaled out
Like I said if I would have done scale why
or X here let's show that off instead
Let's set the health to oneAnd attack them.
He just kind of dances and turns away like
he's going to run away
I don't want to make it look like he's
running away I want to make sure it is
implied that we have vanquished this
baddieAnd.
Oh yeah there is one thing I want to show
off
So as of now this application is somewhat
difficult actually
Because we don't have it set up to
accumulate potionsBecause if I don't
actually use my potion right now and I hit
twice.
I pretty much waste the potionSo we can add
in a kind of a.
Dicey way
Making our potions kind of delayed so
technically if I am fast enough I can
actually click this again
While it's still accumulatingAnd let's do
that by actually creating a set timeout.
So our main.js is actually go to our drink
potion
And all this is going to be perfect the way
it is
But now we're going to add a little bit of
functionality with our set timeoutIn a set
timeout.
Takes intoTakes into arguments.
It takes in a Timeout number
In the function that you want to actually
send through it so the function will be
first so we'll
actually we're going to make a health up
function and I want this to occur after
three seconds
So now I need to actually create that Health
up
Cuz right now if I say this and we go over
and try to drink our potion
We should encounter an areaWhoops when I
drink my potion.
Oh yes this is because I just actually made
that functionSo technically if I comment
this out.
When I hit this potion I shouldIf I actually
get a potion first.
Oh my goodness so let's give myself a potion
here
Just get a little bit of attackWhen I click
on this potion we get that reference air
help is not defined.
I kind of skipped ahead there and I already
made that function
So now we actually have a function that's
calling to hear it's not doing anything but
it won't air out
So within this health up function we want to
still do everything that we're doing in
pretty much right here
We're just going to move it down
We just want everything to be on a timeout
of 3 seconds so we kind of want when you hit
that button
It's not going to increase your health by 25
until after 3 seconds
So let's save that and show off kind of
what's going on thereSo like I said before.
If I use the health potion right now it
wouldn't make sense because I don't have 25
Health
but now I can use that health potion it's
not going to go on for another 3 secondsAnd
there it went.
So just gives the user more time to actually
click that potion
So once again I get that health potion I got
the three seconds
Or you can sit here and wait toIf you're
really low. Oh dang he smoked me.
And that's how we can use our set timeouts
the main thing to always remember oh sorry
And that's how we will be using our set
timeout
The main thing to remember is that function
needs to go in this first argument and the
time limit and
once again this is in millisecond so 3,000
milliseconds will be 3 seconds and it will
occur after 3 seconds
So another cool little thing I'm just going
to add is a page load
And I'll actually set this to the topSo
function page load. And.
This isn't going to beThis isn't going to be
for everyone this is just more of a.
Funny cool thing to add cuz I'm going to add
thisWindow alert that I made.
And this is going to essentially as soon as
the page load and I'll have it set to the
top so I'm going to actually invoke this
within my JavaScript
And since it's at the top this is going to
happen before anything else happens within
this project
So from here if I refresh my page
I get this alert that gives me the storyline
of what the code Works Crusaders going to be
And then it's going to give me this will you
have what it takes to Vanquish the coding
virus maybe we'll see
And now you kind of get that introduction to
that actual web application